Hot wings are amazingly, amazingest, everything amazing.
What is your all-time favorite food?
Pizza.
Pepperoni pizza.
Hamburgers and french fries.
My favorite food is pancakes.
I love mac and cheese.
It grows your body healthy and strong.
Because the syrup is yummy and it's kind of fluffy.
It all just melts in your mouth after you bite the crust.
It tastes like bananas mixed up in sauce.
Oh my God.
A pancake.
Yum.
This thing is huge!
It's funny.
This bowl is ginormous.
Taller.
It kind of looks too big.
It's not gonna come out.
Okay, I'm gonna move it.
Kind of big  but it's really yummy.
I don't know why but them being so big really makes it seem more delicious.